hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome back to let's play a castle
of devastating diseases I've got big
news
I was just firing up the game today and
I saw an announcement amnesia a machine
for pigs got a release Dayton is
available for pre-purchase on Steam it's
gonna come out September 10th which
means three weeks from now just over
three weeks for about four weeks from
now I'm so excited that is incredible
it has a release date finally I haven't
seen any like articles about it all I
saw was that as soon as I was firing
this up today I saw that so I'm so
incredibly excited about that you do not
understand how excited I am that that is
going to happen oh my god okay oh yeah
I'm sorry I got a little too excited
there let's get into the game now I'm
like so excited I thought it would never
come out I thought they were gonna wait
till Halloween but oh my god oh oh I got
it right around the corner it's finally
happening oh my god sorry
this at amnesia was the first game I
ever let's plate and I absolutely loved
it to death and of you piggies you're
gonna get the whole game about you well
you're gonna be dead and ground up into
little bitty itty bitty piggy bits but I
mean that's still a game about you you
can't be too upset about that
yes picked up libraries machine room key
- what does that mean
machine room keep - I've got a knife go
to mess with me okay whatever I don't
care I'm too happy I'm too happy to be
thwarted by stupid grammatical errors oh
by the way has anybody I only recently
started watching your grammar sucks by
jacksFilms and those that this dev is
delirious that is absolutely hilarious I
love that to death anyway I'm just a
little crazy I've got the devastating
disease in my and my brain blood in my
brain blood I've got it all up here in
my brain blood and it's affecting me in
strange ways but I was already weird
before Sharri nurses effective my my
okay anyway so this is the darker
portion of the castle I don't know how
close I am to the end I didn't think
that this was an incredibly long custom
story
not that I care either way I like it a
good custom stories and this isn't has
been a good one just because it's been
so involved and so very intricate in its
detail except for the grammar but then I
forgive that the door is jammed from the
other side how about a crowbar key okay
from the other side was that mean there
is a way in
osya way and except there's kind of a
dark spot on that wall maybe if i ah no
that did not work mmm even my immense
muscles could not bust through it yeah I
don't like the sound of that music like
discern of any of this I don't know why
I need my lantern so much it's actually
kind of bright you know it was weird
because in that basement there was Sun
streaming through but now it's raining
and dark and overcast and yet there is
nothing okay this is strange that
doesn't seem to be anything here but
where do I use this library key that I
found so much have epicly parkour
ow my balls well this is strange
ah seems to be something wrong here the
engine
there must be an engine which isn't
running properly find a way to get
behind that door well I bet in there but
there is a locked door in there that is
blocked from the other side now how I
get into that is a greater question see
I have a key to the libery
to the machine room and the library does
I mean there was a door over here that
led to the library I think I recall that
maybe over here
no those section two but over here there
may have been something to the lab
hmmm yes the library have I been in here
before I don't exactly recall my
memories failing me I shouldn't have did
okay alright then
is that gonna it's gonna be can't use
that there can use either someone's
creaking the floorboards oh oh that was
the winner got it
alright weird fog aha
that's not exactly a machine room but
whatever why would there be a machine
room in the light oh I thought I heard
that unlock that must be some kind of
opening I did it didn't I did it wait a
minute there's a whole book what did
that did oh I know I need to find
another key to the other door and then I
can get oh I need to find another key
where do I find another key there must
have been something in the dormitories
that I missed because um I found the one
key in the other room ergo there must be
something up here and now I gotta find a
way into that room I've gotta find a way
there must be a way that I didn't see
some way around or inside or through how
strange
[Music]
wait a minute what this door was locked
I swear it was what happened what what
it said that it was blocked from the
other side didn't it or did the is it
the room I went in no this was it
I'm so confused don't get me rose I'm so
confused right now
I thought no maybe no I was wrong no I
was wrong okay I'm losing my mind this
is the door that was blocked from the
other side okay excuse me I'm in I'm a
great big idiot shut up everybody it's
not my fault I am just less stupid
maybe there's a false back to this maybe
there's a way through around it
maybe there's something behind it I
don't know how to get to there I don't
know how to get to there what is this
dirty pile of clothes concealing a hole
in the ground no see some above that no
I'm up there no gotta think outside the
box here there's this big black rod on
this wall what does it mean what does it
all mean
I hear some I hear some hmm
maybe there was some indeed behind here
aha yeah I knew it
yes I'm a genius of looking right out
that window yes so smart so smart so
smart key yes
library's machine room key number one
number one just like me okay number one
dude let me add re run out the window
and jump over come here come here you're
gonna be like a charging bull and you're
going to draw I don't know
wait hang on maybe I can get maybe I can
move this No all right you can't climb
out the window can you does that be
totally cheating I would just be the
utmost cheat alert doctor dun da da da
da da what are you gonna do you can't do
anything to me get out of here need to
find me a weapon this son of a [ __ ]
no it's funny I've heard that they made
em need you just in like three weeks so
the fact that one of their scary no no
no no no no no that's a suit of a [ __ ]
that was a son of a [ __ ] just I had
that it wouldn't let me through
not wow great job whatever the hell your
name is dr. douche that's who you are
dr. dick all right I'm ready for you
you're not gonna come out all right
that is one thing that is gonna change
in a machine for pigs because the
monsters will not go away if they get
you that's one of the things and they're
adaptive and changing and they're also
Tibetan oh my god it's gonna be great oh
my god a machine for pigs is coming up
oh my god oh yeah I remember this place
is kind of spooky all right push it the
button push it up on push a little
button and then we can go through this
door and then we can turn on the
machines and wood what am I supposed to
do here I don't know these numbers I
didn't get a note oh here's another all
right this is eenie engine which opens
main external door the engine has three
parts which have their own levers in the
library some of the levers must be equal
with each part what the engine has three
parts which have their own letters in
the library some of the levers must
equal with each part
what okay how about say you better not
being a douche enough on me
don't be do [ __ ] up okay so there's a
letter library oh now I've gone
cross-eyed okay some of the some of the
some of them with Shana the bar must
equal this some of them I need to light
the rest of these cuz I'm not gonna
waste the oil I'm gonna be here forever
I'm gonna be here for freaking ever and
why is it gonna be dark in here
light it up no turn the boxes left oh my
gosh dang it
okay so dude said there was a letter
somewhere in the library I don't see no
lower all I hear is creak eNOS creaky D
key ah that'll be helpful creaky
deaconess why my creepiness alright you
know what I'm gonna throw ran off piss
balls okay there we go I'm just gonna
throw random levers till I get to
victory yup that was good yeah it's good
let's see not too high yeah that's yeah
that's probably it
oh yeah oh yeah that's more like it
nope okay no that goes yeah there we go
is that good did I do it oh my god I
don't see any letters ah
[Applause]
I did it yeah I did what did I did I
made him equal six six six on a hunch I
did oh my god I did it oh man I've been
there forever I am sorry about that guys
that took forever I still didn't know
what a beat I misread the thing I
thought I said letters it still said
levers I'm an idiot on that part but
that didn't help me at all I didn't know
what that meant
okay all right okay who's that who's
that what happened
did something a lab said of preventing
me from escaping it's something happen
or am I allowed to go um I gotta go I
seem to be going slowly very slowly
hello no not that way all right
Oh more gobby goop I can smell the fresh
air right beside that gobby goop hmm no
I'm still locked I hope one of my
patients hasn't gone there why didn't I
leave in the beginning I should have
done that a long time ago freedom
freedom maybe that's my house right
there ah tomatillos sweep away all this
horrible nightmare good thing I'll be
totally safe inches from the castle oh
no not my home okay whatever whatever
finally I got out from that horrific
castle or did I know now nobody will
ever go there again
or will they die that is the end okay
that is it
ha all right so the exciting news being
that my machine for pigs is literally
right around the corner it is so close
you can taste it it's right on top of
your tongue it's right there I'm so
excited for it's gonna be Fantasma chol
and I can't wait this is officially the
last custom story for the force family
age of that I will play and then the
next taste of amnesia you will get will
be like a solid every part of amnesia
will be up next so I'm so excited for
that so thank you all so much for
watching click the enemies over in the
annotation for videos that I've done and
as always we'll see you in the next
video
[Music]
stuffed it in my pocket